Speaker 1: President Joe Biden has given his
first speech since announcing that he will
be running for reelection in 2024.
Now failed former President Donald Trump.
Trump was drunk.
Trump or Trump was massively triggered by
Joe Biden's announcement.
We'll get to that later.
Let's first start with a speech given by Joe
Biden.
Now, you all know Joe Biden's not my favorite.
I'm not like a Joe Biden, you know, cheerleader.
But he seems significantly energized by this
announcement.
He spoke yesterday at North America's Building
Trades Union legislative conference, his first
speech since announcing the 2024 campaign.
Standing ovations.
Energy going after the maggots.
Let's take a listen.
Speaker 2: Billionaires should be paying a
lower tax rate than a construction worker,
a school teacher, a firefighter.
Unidentified: A cop nurse.
I mean, it's wrong.
It's simply wrong.
If you didn't.
Speaker 2: Through this, you think I was making
it up?
Meanwhile, guess what?
My mega Republican friends in Congress are
up to.
The speaker of the House went to Wall Street
last week for huge cuts in important programs,
cut all discretionary spending by 22%, including
ones I just named programs millions of working
and middle class Americans count on.
At the same time, here it is.
My Republican colleagues are pushing some
tax giveaways for the wealthiest Americans
and biggest corporations.
They'd rather see kids and seniors struggle
and eat what they need.
People on Medicaid lose their health care.
Veterans lose access to doctor's visits.
And as part of it, by the way, not a job.
Then cut subsidies to big oil that made $200
billion and Big Pharma the wealthiest corporate
corporations.
And talk about raising gyros to stop the subsidies.
Same old trickle down dressed up in MAGA clothing.
Only worse.
Speaker 1: All right.
So certainly we're grading a little bit on
a curve, but for the sort of level of energy
that we sometimes see from Joe Biden, certainly
energized, saying it is time to finish the
job.
The crowd chanting four more years.
Speaker 2: Reason.com, The New York Times.
Make manufacture greater Again was the title
of the article and want to say.
President Biden appears presiding over the
kind of manufacturing surge that Trump had
promised.
Unidentified: Oh.
We're not making this stuff up.
This is real.
Speaker 2: This time to finish the job.
Finish the job.
And I also are.
Speaker 1: Oh, yeah.
Oh.
All right, So, listen, I'm not going to pretend
this was the most electrifying moment from
Joe Biden.
But the point here is the polling looks pretty
okay for Joe Biden.
And there are people who are laughing this
off.
I got emails from saying, David, Joe Biden
obviously can't win reelection.
It's not obvious to me.
It's not obvious to me at all.
Oh, but the polls the polls were spot on in
2020.
And, you know, we don't need to we don't need
to do this game at this point in time.
But Joe Biden certainly seems ready.
And we're going to see Trump's reaction.
We're going to see the debate schedule.
We're going to see all sorts of different
things.
But in the midst of it, we have to talk about
the latest from Chris Christie.